[Musique]
une voix qui vient du ciel et qui
demande aux habitants de limiter leurs
déplacements au strict minimum
ce n'est pas un film de science fiction
nous sommes à saint-esprit une ville qui
fait le choix d air pour mettre en garde
la population contre tout déplacement
abusif et monsieur le maire a pris soin
de prévenir sa population du passage de
ce drone qui appartient à une société
privée
d'ailleurs même sous facebook il ya une
page qui qui dit que la ville était
surveillé suite à la crise par les
douanes nous avons l'habitude de
d'ailleurs de travailler avec la vidéo
du saint-esprit par ailleurs quand y
avait le carnaval ou la fête patronale
côté pratique voilà comment ça marche le
pilote balade son drone sur la commune
et quand ils voient un rassemblement et
dans son message il vous est recommandé
de ne pas sortir ou éviter toute
contamination
merci laquelle des véhicules dont une
chasse aux semences au bas denses
évident il en riant ensuite les images
sont automatiquement envoyées sur le
téléphone portable des policiers qui
interviennent en cas de besoin
nous savons qu'il fait trois sorties par
jour et ils nous renvoient les images et
s'il ya quelque chose qui cloche
à ce moment là on peut savoir si on doit
faire une intervention ou pas si c'est
nécessaire on va sur les lieux c'est pas
nécessaire faut dire qu'on travaille on
attend une nette entre la boire ce que
radio mairie nous sommes au téléphone
régulièrement pas témoin toute la
journée et ont fait remonter
l'information afin de savoir quelles
procédures adoptées et choses plutôt
curieux c'est que depuis que ce droit ne
circule il y a moins de monde dans les
rues
c'est à quoi que les spirit et obéissent
aux voix qui viennent dans peau dure
c'est assez aussi aux nouveaux moyens
technologiques nous ça permet
effectivement de défauts mais ya pas que
ça au moins parce qu'elle marque mac ça
les gens ne comprennent pas ouattara
j'ai vu la cote est là
j'aime mars étaient toutes au combat
pour faire rentrer à la maison
c'est ma première sortie d'un pub dix
jours pour la formation et c'est toute
l'europe
autre détail qui a son importance les
gants des policiers ils ont été
commandés ighli ya quelques mois du côté
du saint-esprit on est plutôt bien
équipé
la ville du saint-esprit est donc sous
vidéosurveillance en savez il y à
quelques caméras ici posée à gauche à
droite mais désormais il ya un drone qui
trois fois par jour surveille les
différents déplacements afin de prévenir
tous ceux qui seraient tentés de se
déplacer sans motif et sans raison
valable de rester chez eux pour éviter
la propagation du virus